[Music]
your grandma wants you to be james bond
will you do that yeah i mean yeah
perfect
miles is all in supporting the campaign
his grandma started on twitter to have
him replace daniel craig as
double-oh-seven you'll never see me
again i think we're actors yeah so maybe
you can
mix it up a little bit will it be a top
gun sequel oh that i mean that would be
that would be great but that's all up to
to tc it's all up to tom i've been uh
having some conversations with him about
it but you know we'll see all right well
you intimidate some of these guys you
say i got a shirtless scene
yeah shirtless scene would look a little
different
these days we shot that a couple years
ago but yeah we'll see maybe i'll give a
little wiggle if i get a nice eagle or
something okay we didn't get a wiggle
but we did get lots of fun one-on-ones
with stars is that one of your boys out
with you today yeah that's my son my
youngest son joe is catting for me
wait a minute so i get you instead of
michelle
what's wrong with that uh it's a
once pretty one's not
check this out that's a steph curry fan
knocking out 30 push-ups in exchange for
an autograph you're getting ready to
host the espys have you have you been
working on your hosting game and uh in
your monologue in it been uh been
grinding so we got some good ideas
dangerous when i got the mic though so
we'll see what happens
how's the back because we see you out on
the course doing yoga stretching the
back what's going on well i've had two
back surgeries and so if you practice as
much as i do and play i mean i do
an hour to two hours a step before i
ever hit a golf ball it's good right now
aaron rodgers hit the links with new ink
fans are pointing out how similar it is
to that of his rumored new girlfriend
blue of earth it's the 18th year that
aaron's attended the american century
championship presented by american
century investments i've played with
michael jordan over the years jt the
pressure to actually perform is it
definitely picks up
another event vet alfonso ribeiro have
you had a chance to talk to will uh i
have not because he's a golfer too i
thought you maybe you all got out
engulfed and had a chance to talk or
work things out no
didn't done to work out okay
[Music]
you